et maintenant avant la troisième partie
de double jeu une page de publicité tout
sur trois minutes tout le monde reste en
place merci
en outre un droit de couper ton émission
avec de la pub ouais bon
enfin c'est débandade en ce moment ils
mettent des bandes annonces mais il n'y
a pas de pub non c'est pas de la pub
c'est des bandes annonces pour d'autres
émissions de la chaîne
d'accord c'est ça a dit non la pub ils
n'ont pas le droit mais en droit de
mettre des bandes annonces pour d'autres
évasions
maintenant que plus que ça ça va les
miss se passe bien tu es content ah
ouais sainté la fin à cette adresse
tu connaissais francis non c'est connu
comme ça ici je vivais mes chances je
sais ce qui fait j'aime beaucoup ce que
mes trajets envie de te le demander mais
c'est un peu emmerdant voit donc pas
l'air triste en ce moment tu avais l'air
triste un peu plus un peu intrusif oui
un peu usé sans un peu ouais pourquoi
main
des emmerdes
par exemple chercher non non non mais
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec kouchner
exactement marien si tu veux moi j'ai vu
en vitesse j'ai rien compris il ya
comment sinclair qui m'a appelé à la
maison pour que je viens de faire
dans l'émission que coup de poing sur la
table machin de devenir un moment donné
apporter la contradiction et puis
j'ai vu l'émission et puis je suis
rentré et puis j'étais atterré
d'entendre kouchner dire ce qu'ils
disaient et puis tu vois c'est
épouvantable a l'impression que cit
avait voté non à maastricht était un cul
terreux puisqu'il disait sur les
agriculteurs c'est épouvantable lors
j'ai réagi jeudi que que moi je trouvais
que quand il faisait des actions
humanitaires c'était formidable mais que
quand je l'entendais parler de tenir ce
discours politicien ça me ça me ça me
choquer et puis au bout d'un moment
qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre kouchner
et le pen battue c'est à un moment donné
j'avais fait un débat et puis et puis
et moi ce qui m'avait choqué c'est que
si tu veux en ce moment c'est clair ils
font une campagne anti campagne pour
faire une majorité de progrès autour du
oui pour empêcher la droite de revenir
bon et ça m'embête d'entendre kouchner
tenir ce discours tu vois moi quand il
quand il est en action je le trouve
formidable mais quand y tient ce
discours pour issa nous bon alors il
avait à un moment donné je l'avais je
lui avais parlé de ça dit à le pen en
gros pourquoi vous êtes content
maastricht vous êtes plus de ces curieux
pour plus de sécurité et en fait
maastricht c'est plus de sécurité
donc j'avais l'impression tu vas qu'il
essayait de grappiller des voix comme ça
et ça m'a choqué moi je lui dis ça et
puis il m'a dit c'est pas vrai j'ai pas
fait ça alors je dis arrêtez de mentir
tu vois comme il l'avait dit lui trois 3
jours plus tôt j'étais sur le plateau de
paul amar et qui m'avait aussi il avait
dit à gisèle halimi
c'est faux ou gisèle ce que vous dites
est faux mensonges dont elle n'a pas
traité de [ __ ] elle tu vois elle n'a
rien répondu
et moi quand je dis arrêtez de mentir il
m'a dit je voudrais pas de menteur je
dis bah écoutez moi je vous dis arrêtez
de mentir une dit alors vous êtes un
[ __ ]
ça veut dire ça veut dire en gros que
quand ministre
tu as le droit de dire un citoyen
français ou une citoyenne comme gisèle
halimi quel état le droit de l'accusé de
mensonges
mais quand tu es un citoyen français
t'as pas le droit de mettre en doute la
parole d'un ministre
et depuis on m'a nul des émissions il ya
3 mais qui m'attendait pour me casser la
gueule devant chez moi et je commence à
en avoir marre tu vois et je trouve ça
un peu flipper et franchement tu vois je
c'est la première fois de ma vie c'est
pas la première fois que je m'engage
parce que j'ai jamais mis mes idées dans
ma poche il dans sa lettre
ta gueule ta gueule ta gueule qu'un peu
qu'un peu un poète qui descend du salut
non non si tu veux c'est pas ça c'est
que c'est que qu'est ce que je voulais
dire qu'est ce que j'étais en train de
dire là
maintenant tu dis que gisèle halimi a le
droit de dire des trucs et toi t'as pas
droit non si tu veux ce que ce que
tu dises a de la gueule ouais et je peux
le redire encore oui je disais que c'est
pas la première fois que je m'engage
politiquement parce que j'ai jamais mis
mes idées dans la poche
en revanche si tu veux pour la première
fois c'est sûr que si j'avais j'avais je
m'étais couchée sur les listes de jack
lang pour le oui à maastricht
si jal était partie en vacances avec ma
femme au lieu de
de d'occuper le déan avec les
intermittents du spectacle et de me
battre pour que leurs droits soient
préservés c'est sûr que j'aurais moins
d'emmerdements aujourd'hui alors quand
en plus j'entends des gens à me dire que
c'est pour faire de la pub alors que je
me fait interdire en télé que je me fait
traîner dans la boue par tous là pour la
première fois de ma vie ça me fait
flipper parce que j'ai tu vois je suis
déçu parce que franchement je pensais
qu'on était dans une démocratie quand tu
as des gens qui se disent socialistes et
qui font ça eh ben tu te dis que c'est
horrible quoi que c'est affreux
attention lenglen dans quinze saisons de
dieu ça veut dire qu'ils sont capables
de tout ça veut dire que ils ont tous
les droits et hop est un droit que c'est
de fermer ta gueule à mireval
on y retourne ok
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux